alors il charge il s'agit dans cette
amendement de d'anticiper l'application
du dispositif de l'alinéa 3 et de
l'avancée au 1er juillet 2023 je vous
remercie merci merci
effectivement monsieur le ministre vient
d'en parler donc c'est c'est
l'anticipation d'un an de la mise en
oeuvre de cette obligation justement de
verser sur un compte domicilié en France
ou dans la zone européenne élargie les
prestations sociales soumises à
condition de résidence en France il
serait évidemment préférable d'appliquer
cette mesure le plus rapidement possible
c'est la raison pour laquelle Nathalie
Goulet propose de l'appliquer dès le 1er
juillet 2023 et non pas attendre 2024
donc nous sollicitons l'avis du
Gouvernement sur cette proposition
c'est une disposition qui a beaucoup
fait parler effectivement c'était une
mesure qui était proposée par Madame
Goulet dans sa proposition de loi je
crois que c'était l'article 14 que j'ai
reprises dans le projet de loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale en
première lecture à l'Assemblée nationale
et j'ai porté un amendement du
Gouvernement pour conditionner le
versement des prestations sociales
soumises à condition de résidence à un
compte bancaire français ou européen et
ça a été très commenté puisque ensuite
il y a eu beaucoup d'articles beaucoup
de commentaires sur Internet les réseaux
sociaux que j'ai regardé
l'écrasante majorité évidemment des
personnes étaient favorables à cette
mesure et la soutenait mais un
commentaire qui revenait le plus c'est
pourquoi attendre un an puisque on a
prévu dans le texte effectivement que ça
soit au 1er janvier 2024 on avait
effectivement prévu ce délai d'un an
d'abord pour être sûr que les caisses de
sécurité sociale soient prêtes pour
mettre en place cette obligation ça
c'est la première chose et ensuite pour
qu'il y ait un délai de prévenance pour
des personnes qui bénéficieraient
effectivement de ces prestations
sociales sur un compte étranger qu'elles
aient le temps de s'ouvrir un compte
français ou européen mais depuis
l'adoption du PLFSS en première lecture
à l'Assemblée nous avons échangé avec
les caisses de sécurité sociale qui nous
ont dit qu'elle pourrait être prête
plutôt je pense par ailleurs que nos
concitoyens ou les personnes concernées
ont eu vent de cette mesure et l'ont
entendu donc je donne un avis de sagesse
à cet amendement qui prévoit d'avancer
de six mois et ça veut dire mettre en
œuvre cette obligation au 1er juillet
2023 en lui et place du 1er janvier 2024
avis de la commission sur le coup
ce ministre contenu de ces éléments je
pense qu'il est intéressant de voter cet
amendement pour fixer la date plutôt
possible donc à lui favora monsieur
Valentin
comme j'avais effectivement rapporté sur
la PPL de Madame Goulet je me réjouis
monsieur le ministre que vous ayez
effectivement repris et que vous
repreniez aussi cet amendement parce que
c'est vrai que plutôt sera le mieux
pour éviter effectivement les fraudes
donc je me réjouis mais je j'en profite
pour vous poser une question puisque
vous n'étiez pas là lors de la
discussion générale c'est sur les
estimations que nous avons sollicité
notamment auprès des caisses et en
particulier auprès de la Caisse
d'Assurance Maladie et que nous
attendons par donc nous attendons
impatiemment et j'espère que vous
pourrez accélérer le la procédure pour
que nous puissions avoir on espérait
pour ce PLFSS nous puissions avoir des
estimations qui soient fondées sur un
échantillonnage un peu scientifique en
tous les cas méthodique et éviter tous
les fantasmes qui tournent autour des
manœuvres ou des des fraudes qui sont
surestimés à l'évidence
merci Madame pansement
oui mais merci monsieur le Président on
peut être que d'accord avec avec la
disposition ce que je remarque quand
même c'est que vous avez vous mettez
beaucoup de moyens pour vous diligenter
beaucoup de moyens quand il s'agit
effectivement de ce qu'on appelle la
fraude sociale aux prestations et c'est
très bien mais je vous rappelle quand
même que la fraude d'ailleurs on devrait
toujours préciser de quel fraude sociale
on parle la fraude sociale au cotisation
et neuf fois plus importante ma collègue
il a dit son rendement est plus que
ridicule donc monsieur le ministre quand
est-ce que vous allez diligenter les
moyens à la hauteur de la fraude sociale
au cotisations
merci à toi de vous avez d'abord
monsieur lévrier vous allez pas vouloir
répondre avant
merci monsieur le Président juste une
toute petite remarque on peut imaginer
que nombre de ces retraites sont des
petites retraites et que donc nombre de
personnes qui les touchent ont peut-être
des difficultés sur tout ce qui est
document administratif donc je trouve
que le délai de six mois est très bien
excellent à une condition c'est que la
communication autour se passe très bien
aussi pour ne pas pénaliser des gens de
bonne foi qui n'arriveraient pas
s'informer sur ce sujet merci
merci monsieur le ministre
oui merci monsieur le Président
peut-être pour répondre à différentes
interventions d'abord effectivement je
n'étais pas en discussion générale et je
vous prie de mon excusé j'étais à
l'Assemblée pour le PLFR mais j'étais
représenté ici par ma collègue Olivia
Grégoire mais pour vous répondre oui on
a besoin de pouvoir davantage documenter
ce dont on parle il y a aujourd'hui
multitude de rapports et d'études qui
ont été réalisés vous avez des études
qui ont été réalisées par l'Assurance
Maladie s'agissant des professionnels de
santé vous en avez qui ont été réalisés
par la CNAV s'agissant de la SPA ou du
minimum vieillesse vous avez des
rapports de la Cour des comptes vous
avez des rapports sénatoriaux moi ce que
je souhaite c'est mettre en place un
comité indépendant d'évaluation de la
fraude aux prestations sociales je
précise ça sera pas une nouvelle un
nouveau comité avec des moyens entre
guillemets humains etc on va on mettra à
disposition les moyens des
administrations de Bercy et de la
sécurité sociale mais auquel on veut
associer des parlementaires des
personnalités qualifiées pour être
capables d'être plus efficace et
exhaustif sur ce qu'on est capable de
mesurer de cette fraude manifestations
sociales donc ça c'est un chantier qu'on
va lancer dans les prochaines semaines
les prochains mois pour vous répondre
madame la sénatrice évidemment moi je ne
fais pas de concurrence où je n'oppose
pas les fraudes enfin je ne considère
pas qu'il y a un type de fraude qu'il
faut davantage pour suivre que les
autres toutes fraudes est inacceptable
frauder c'est voler c'est miner le pacte
républicain et le pacte social donc
toutes les fraudes doivent faire l'objet
de la même intensité dans la lutte qui
est menée par les pouvoirs publics et je
peux vous dire que mes services à Bercy
s'agissant de la fraude fiscale sont
particulièrement mobilisés l'an dernier
montant record de droits notifié en
matière de fraude fiscale plus de 13
milliards d'euros un 11 milliards
d'euros recouvré on va de records en
record ont renforce nos moyens notamment
aussi avec l'apport du numérique
aujourd'hui vous avez plus de 50% des
contrôles fiscaux qui sont guidés
orientés par l'intelligence artificielle
grâce à des algorithmes qui nous
permettent de détecter des indices et
qui permettent ensuite de guider les
agents vers le contrôle des personnes ou
des institutions qui sont les plus
on va dire ton estime qu'elles sont
qu'il est plus probable qu'elle réalise
des fraudes et sur la fraude aux
cotisations sociales au travail
dissimulé on a vu tout à l'heure j'ai
rappelé l'ambition qui est la nôtre les
moyens dont on dispose donc vraiment de
ce point de vue là toutes les fraudes
doivent être convaincus avec vigueur
merci
après le ministre ces moyens fin
allez-yves Monsieur Merci monsieur le
Président juste d'avoir sur cette
amendement il me paraît indispensable
parce que moi je n'ai pas compris
comment une application au 1er janvier
2024 avait un impact sur la LFSS 2023
donc
je vais jamais vu ça donc voilà donc
évidemment que il vaut mieux mettre la
date en 2023 pour éviter une éventuelle
censure bon et puis pardon monsieur le
Président mais je réagis quand même au
propos du ministre parce que oui on va
être frodé ses volets bon d'accord oui
sauter la barrière du métro c'est fraudé
c'est voler tout n'entraîne pas la même
mobilisation et ne doit pas entraîner la
même mobilisation la fraude
des employeurs la fraude patronale c'est
comme l'évasion fiscale ce sont des
fautes qui sont massives et qui
déstructurent profondément une société
la fraude d'un individu aux prestations
ça doit être sanctionné bien sûr mais la
fraude d'un individu aux prestations
c'est un individu les points la fraude
d'organisation l'évasion fiscale des
multinationales qui ne payent pas
l'impôt en France des dizaines des
centaines de milliards qui échappent aux
sociétés à nos sociétés ce sont des
puissants fasseurs de facteurs de
destructuration de la société et pardon
mais dans vos engagements on vous entend
beaucoup plus sur la fraude au quotidien
aux prestations que sur cette fraude là
bon on note que vous êtes venus pour ce
PLFSS en séance avec nous pour parler de
la fraude malheureusement on vous a pas
vu au moment des recettes de cette
discussion de comment on crée de on crée
des recettes pour notre sécurité sociale
pour les pour les prestations qui sont
versées dans notre pays pour la santé
pour la bon vous êtes venus pour parler
de la fraude et à 80% de la fraude aux
prestations voilà c'est tout
je vais redonner la part le ministre
mais je voudrais qu'on en reste à
l'article non non non non recommande pas
on recommence pas depuis la DG jusque
aux fin des temps et à la préhistoire
non c'est non c'est pas l'article c'est
pas l'article 41 bis mais Monsieur le
Ministre allez-y non merci monsieur le
Président très rapidement je peux
allonger les débats mais je peux pas non
plus laisser dire certaines choses sans
répondre d'abord je rappelle oui j'étais
pas là sur la partie recette j'étais
pour le projet de loi de finances
rectificative à l'Assemblée nationale je
n'ai pas encore le don du biscuitité ni
d'hologramme qui me permettrait d'être
présent dans les deux chambres en même
temps mais je crois être très à
disposition du Sénat régulièrement
j'étais aussi auditionné par la
commission des affaires sociales
récemment sur ces sujets la deuxième
chose que je veux dire c'est que si je
vous écoute vous devriez vous réjouir et
féliciter ce gouvernement ce président
de la République qui ont fait sauter le
verrou de Bercy en 2018 féliciter ce
gouvernement ce président de la
République qui alignent les grandes
entreprises les unes après les autres
pour des mécanismes d'optimisation
fiscale cet été mes services ont mis une
amende record à McDonald's un milliard
de 100 millions d'euros un milliard 200
millions d'euros pour un McDonald's pour
des mécanismes d'optimisation fiscale
encore récemment pour de accompagnement
qui était réalisé par le Crédit Suisse
sur l'optimisation fiscale aussi 300
millions d'euros d'amendes qui ont été
notifiés on a des des amendes qui sont
prononcées et notamment parce qu'on a
des nouveaux leviers via la loi de lutte
contre la fraude en 2018 qui sont
Records et je trouve que vous devriez
plutôt saluer reconnaître cette action
que de considérer que rien n'est fait
puisque c'est absolument pas vrai merci
alors est-ce que cet amendement est
maintenu ou pas
monsieur Hainaut il est maintenu alors
je le mets aux voix je au bout du bout
on ne sait plus avec la vie de quoi
d'ailleurs
monsieur le rapporteur rappelez-nous
après tout ça la vie de la commission
est favorable la vie du Gouvernement est
favorable sagesse sagesse allez le 152
donc avec un avis favorable de la
commission sagesse du gouvernement qui
est pour toc qui est contre ben voilà il
est adopté
[Musique]